شكرًا لك
على مر السنين ، أحدثت التكنولوجيا
ثورة في العالم من حولنا
، والطريقة التي نعيش بها حياتنا التي أعادت تشكيل
الطريقة التي نعمل بها ، ونأكل السفر والتكنولوجيا الحية
، أحدثت أيضًا ثورة في
الطريقة التي نلعب بها بلعبة الجولف الآن في
الواقع الافتراضي المتطور للغاية  المصطلح المستخدم
لوصف بيئة ثلاثية الأبعاد يتم
إنشاؤها بواسطة الكمبيوتر والتي
يمكن استكشافها والتفاعل معها من قبل
شخص وشركة واحدة مقرها أوستن هو
جعل Waves في مساحة الواقع الافتراضي
أسهل طريقة لوصفها هي
لعبة غولف الواقع الافتراضي حتى تتمكن من
اربط سماعة الرأس
في إحدى دوراتنا في العالم الحقيقي
والعب مع الأصدقاء من أي مكان
في العالم معًا في ملعب
في نفس الوقت واستمتع بالجولف في أي
وقت وفي أي وقت في أي وقت من اليوم وفي أي
طقس.
تشمل الدورات التدريبية جزيرة Valhalla Pinehurst Kiwa
وشاطئ Pebble ولكن مع مساحة لعب
كبيرة جدًا ، فكيف يمكن ضمان
استجمام دقيق ، ما كان مذهلاً
هو أننا  تمكنا من القيام بكل
دورة تدريبية حقيقية دون أن يخطو قدمًا في
الدورة التدريبية نفسها فقط من
المحتوى المتاح عبر الإنترنت
، ونحن قادرون على الحصول على جميع البيانات التي
نحتاج إلى القيام بها للقيام بهذه الدورات التدريبية من
مصادر خارجية ، لذلك في كثير من الحالات
إنها نوعًا من بيانات المسح الحكومية
التي تلتقطها
لعدة أسباب وتجعل ذلك متاحًا مجانًا ،
لذلك يستغرق الأمر منا
حوالي أربعة إلى ستة أسابيع للانتقال من
لا شيء على الإطلاق إلى وجود دورة تدريبية
جاهزة للعب في اللعبة
أعلنت شركة Golf Plus الشهر الماضي عن جولة استثمار رفيعة المستوى للغاية
مع توم برادي ستيف
كاري روري ماكلروي وجوردان سبيث من
بين أولئك الذين وضعوا الأموال في شركة التكنولوجيا
الناشئة التي أردنا حقًا العثور على
مجموعة إستراتيجية من الأشخاص تم
شراؤها بالكامل في مهمتنا من
أجل  جعل الوصول إلى لعبة الجولف أكثر سهولة ، كان من
الممتع حقًا التحدث إليهم حول
الطريقة التي نعتقد أن هذا يمكن أن يعمل بها ، وبعد
استخدام هذا أعتقد أنهم كانوا قد
اقتنعوا بفكرة مثل
mayb  هذه هي الطريقة التي يمكنهم من خلالها
إشراك أطفالهم في لعبة الجولف لأنها
نسخة أكثر إثارة من
الرياضة وتأتي مع احتكاك أقل بكثير ،
لذا فقد حان الوقت لمنح Golf Plus
فرصة وأعتقد أنني سأقوم بالاتصال
بصديق  العرض طازجًا في الجزء الخلفي من
فوز بجولة LPGA لتجربته معي
[موسيقى] ،
هذا غريب حقًا يمكنني رؤية
شعرك الأشقر اللطيف الرمزية نحن هنا في
Valhalla في First Tee
Golf Plus هو وضع متعدد اللاعبين يوفر
للمستخدمين الفرصة  إلى الجولف والدردشة
في هذه البيئة الافتراضية التي
توفر بعض التفاصيل المذهلة ، يمكنني
رؤية العشب يتحرك وشفرات العشب
تنطلق ، وهذا أمر غريب
للغاية في الواقع أكثر مما كنت
أتوقعه أثناء اللعب في
ملعب كأس رايدر السابق الشهير ، من العدل أن نقول
إننا  بدأت بداية بطيئة ،
لكنني سددت تسديدة وذهبت لأميال على
اليمين ، لم أفوت أي شيء حتى
الآن مع شطيرة قبل لعبة
[الموسيقى]
الثلاثية ، لكن هذا هو
مستوى راحتنا الذي نماه وأصبحت طريقة اللعب
أكثر صعوبة  لقد صدمت على بعد
ثماني ياردات من الدبوس ، هل تعرف
ما أعتقد أنني سأبقى
وألعب الجولف هنا ،
إنها تسير بيد واحدة
[موسيقى] ،
نعم هناك مباشرة ، تذهب
30. لذا تشارلي كريسماس قادم
لذا فهي مدرجة في قائمة
أمنياتك ، فلن أفهمها ، إنها لعبة رائعة حقًا
[موسيقى]